hi there
hi how are you guys
good what can we do for you tonight
uh no i just um i would like to just
interject a little bit of a woman's
perspective on to jared
this 21 year old you know um
instead of being so
uh
i know most women can be superficial and
we have a little bit of crazy in this
but there are some women out there that
when they find a man
and they love him they will support him
and they will help him to make those
millions
and so
listening to this 21 year old i'm 47. so
i i've been married we have two children
and my i love my husband and you know
i'm
is it easy all the time no but
behind every great hand is a great woman
are you in what way do you support
yeah like i'm like i'm just confused
like what are we talking about yeah
well i just heard you know i i'm just
hearing you guys kind of chat about
women and your your guy's a success and
jiren was sort of a little bit um
i don't know there's just all this
testosterone and i totally respect this
channel i just found it i'm i'm super
impressed with some of the comments i'm
just learning about um so let me ask you
this question michelle is it not prudent
of a man to uh vet a woman that he's
going to invite into his life and if he
discovers that she's crazy not to do
that
oh no absolutely 100
right so 100
so at what point do you
do like
not see that because i'm not not totally
clear on what your statement is here or
what the advice is exactly
i would just say
i guess my statement and uh
my advice to
young men that are
are coming into your show and listening
to that
um
there's some genuine women out there
there's some genuine women that want to
be supportive and want to find the right
man so support the men out there and and
give them some advice on how to find
these genuine women
don't put up with women's [ __ ]
okay
definitely agree with that what else
find who has integrity and who doesn't
how do you identify so integrity in
women are two things that don't
generally go together very well in our
experience
no they don't right because
women are only as loyal as their options
generally speaking
and this is where you try to
use your discernment
to figure that out right
like you guys
i feel like you know
women these days especially and i'm i'm
i'm a little bit of an older generation
and i'm listening to these conversations
and i'm just i'm talking to you guys as
younger men who are coming in and
there's a lot of [ __ ] out there
some of these women are
[ __ ] crazy
yep okay
you need to learn how to
and i'm not
do you have any kids michelle i think
you have two right yes i do i have two
girls okay so let me ask this question
if one of your girls brought home a guy
that
killed like i don't know a skunk or a
cat or something like that in his
backyard and she told you about it like
what would you think of that would you
be like oh yeah you should marry him or
would you tell her to get rid of the guy
no i'd be like why don't you do it
yourself
okay michelle
[Laughter]
okay no
so now we know what we're dealing with
no i'm just saying you know i'm
i
i guess i'm a different breed because
you know i'm
i've studied martial arts i have my
second degree in taekwondo my girls are
in jiu-jitsu right now sorry we're in
under construction in our house right
now so i apologize
yeah it's a total new construction but
um
i love listening to these chats and i
just they're so
i feel like there's so much to
muddle through with trying to find out
you know you guys like
here's the thing michelle this is what
this is what i advise guys to do is to
take their time cool their jets figure
out what she's made of you know see what
happens when stress gets applied to her
in the relationship when you're dealing
with her over a longer term basis is she
a good person does she support your
mission you know
if you need things done is she useful
you know things like that right like
that's generally what you tend to start
with and then you stay away from red
flags like she has daddy issues she's a
feminist she's unhappy and unlucky all
the time she competes with you she keeps
men from her past around i can keep
going she's violent extreme jealousy she
likes to party with her girlfriends in
las vegas over the weekends consistently
covered in tattoos and piercings big
notch counts been with lots of guys
single mommy with multiple kids from
different daddies you know i keep going
down the list there's a lot of stuff
that i tell guys to vet for but
i
like i understand you're newer to the
channel
i'm sorry i just needed uh okay so i'm
probably coming in when you guys aren't
i'm probably way off task here so i
apologize for taking up the time i just
as a as a mom and an old older mom i
didn't become a mom until i was older
and you know yeah i've been married in
the past and you know i just
are you still married today
yeah
yeah yeah yeah and i love them dearly
we've been yeah we have our two kids
together and we own a business we we do
a business together
we work together is it easy all the time
no but um
i love him and i love my children and so
i make it work you know and if a woman
can't do that for you then
piss off you know don't waste your time
do not waste your time so another
question
how'd you find the channel like what
what brought you here what search term
were you looking for you just stumbled
across it
people don't like to write yeah it's
usually kept a secret
oh my bad i didn't mean to call you you
told me by first name though so i i owe
it to you it's it's it's a friendly dick
though no
no no not at all i have totally respect
that i can hold my own and i i take full
responsibility for my own self and my
own constitution so i'm good so
um no i just he he had a couple of
things it was um actually about
economics was mostly the primary primary
reason like within the last six weeks
and but um i've really enjoyed just
hearing his commentary and the channel
and just hearing these young men and men
like you like come in and what's your
opinions about women and what you hear
and i've just i've learned a lot you
know as a
a mid middle aged
woman with children and um it's been a
great it's actually been quite
refreshing i've actually really enjoyed
it um do i like do i agree with
everything no but there's a lot of
i've dealt with women in my life i might
i keep my smirk my circle of friends
very small
because women
the best people at spotting crazy women
are other women
okay and you know at least five chicks
that if a male you know was going to go
out with them you would run up to him
and go stay away from her stay well away
from her
yep
that's 100 50
all right michelle thanks for joining us
tonight
i appreciate hey guys i really hope that
you enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you